au cinéma les yeux d'elsa en cette fin
d'année scolaire
on va essayer de faire se rassembler les
familles autour du cinéma et dans cette
salle de cinéma avec le festival les
yeux pleins d'étoilés sa neuvième
édition et on souhaite que les gens
viennent passer des bons moments en
famille avec leurs enfants entre
grands-parents et petits-enfants dans
cette salle de cinéma pour partager et
construire des souvenirs ensemble
alors on va avoir une soirée ciné
frisson qui s'adresse plus évidemment
aux adolescents et aux gens qui aiment
le cinéma d'horreur avec eux et prince
des ténèbres mais on va aussi avoir du
cinéma de patrimoine avec cyrano de
bergerac
on va aussi avoir des films des vraies
comédies comme le retour du héros de
laurent tirard avec dujardin et mélanie
thierry qu'on a passés ont déjà cette
année mais qui est tellement drôle qu'on
avait envie de leur montrer le roi et
l'oiseau grand film de cinéma
d'animation français un mix ce film
qu'on vous invite à venir découvrir ou
redécouvrir une salle de cinéma c'est
toujours une expérience formidable
et puis on va rediffuser des films qui
ont été passés dans le cadre de école et
cinéma dans le département cette année
le garçon est le monde et la petite
vendeuse de soleil un film sénégalais
deux petites merveilles que les enfants
dans les écoles ont découvert cette
année et qu'on invite à venir découvrir
avec leurs familles et avec leurs
parents à faire découvrir ce film
et puis pour finir le dimanche 30 juin
on fera une journée autour
le samedi 29 juin et le dimanche 30 juin
on fera deux journées autour du cinéma
avec des films comme capitaine morten
rênes d'un été où fera des ateliers
d'accompagnement autour de ses films et
puis le dimanche 30 juin au matin à 10
heures
ainsi les comptes pour les plus petits
et pour partager en famille à un moment
original de cinéma et de spectacles
vivants alors j'espère vous retrouver le
plus nombreux possible à partir du 21
juin
pour le ciné frisson et jusqu'au 30 juin
pour cette journée d'animation au cinéma
les yeux d'elsa
[Musique]